bonjour on décrypte ensemble ce qui
s'est passé hier et et les suites
surtout ce Conseil de sécurité qui va
donc se réunir en urgence que peut
donner un tel rendez-vous alors c'est
sensibilisé effectivement le Conseil de
sécurité sur ce qui s'est passé après
aujourd'hui on dispose des informations
de part et d'autrre et c'est toute la
difficulté hein c'est d'avoir une
enquête qui dans ces cas-là prendra du
temps qui demandera d'avoir beaucoup
plus de précision alors qu'est-ce qu'on
sait aujourd'hui on sait clairement que
il y a eu un avion militaire de
transport c'est pas un avion civil c'est
bien un avion militaire de transport qui
a été abattu dans la zone frontalière
côté russe donc la théorie des Russes
qui est de dire c'était un avion qui
était en train de s'envoler de belgorode
il portait à son bord 65 prisonniers
ainsi que neuf russes en tout parce
qu'on ne lescide pas mais il y avait
trois soldats plus les membres de
l'équipage et qu'ils ont été tirés par
des missiles et que donc du coup l'avion
s'est abattu il devait se rendre en fait
au poste de garde donc qui est
transfrontalier euh là où il dev avait
relâcher des prisonniers et faire un
échange c'est classique aujourd'hui des
échanges entre les prisonniers russes et
les prisonniers ukrainien donc c'est
tout à fait logique ce qu'explique les
Russes à ce niveau-là au niveau
ukrainien de quoi parle-t-on au niveau
ukrainien on dit oui on sait qu'il peut
y avoir des avions de transport qui ont
des prisonniers à leur bord simplement
dans ces cas-là on est prévenu et on
dispose dans ces cas-là aussi d'un avis
de ce qui on a on n pas à sillonner la
zone aérienne donc à partir du moment
donné où on n pas eu cet avis là euh on
pense que on at tirait parce que au
départ c'était un avion qui avait des
missiles finalement les Russes les
Ukrainiens ont enlevé cette petit motif
et depuis on ne sait plus rien voilà
c'est vrai que le président Zelinski
aujourd'hui s'exprime aux Nations Unies
c'est aussi un pays aujourd'hui qui est
toujours en train de combattre et qui
n'a plus beaucoup d'armement qui n'a
plus beaucoup de munition les États-Unis
elles-mêmes viennent de dire qu'elles
n'ont plus d'argent puisque la plupart
de l'argent gardé pour Israël merci
beaucoup Armel pour le décryptage